hello it looks beautiful
photos of my face remember I'm on yeah
[Music]
this week on my drunk kitchen we are in
place of Hana we're doing a secret my
drunk kitchen that she doesn't even know
about because we want to talk about her
TV show we're very excited for her this
is an episode a parody episode of my
drunk kitchen in honor of I heart food
Hannah Hart's new Food Network
television show coming out in a week so
go ahead and set your DVRs [ __ ] today
we thought it would be fun because we
have a lot of memories attached with our
girl Hannah with the food buff because
one of the things that we all come is
right on is when whenever we've all
three gotten really really drunk
together never happened never next
morning we all want to kind of cleanse
our sins so we created our inter
personal holiday called Super Bowl
Sunday yeah where we go and we eat [ __ ]
hungover as a means to heal ourselves
fun makes me [ __ ] which is a great way
to a like really cleans out right see I
just assumed that I've drank so much
play before that so I have diarrhea
neither one of us have made before so
which I think you've been lined with how
Hannah hopper it's on my joint kitchen
we are not gonna use regular pasta
however we are going to use pasta zero
which is a precooked pasta made out of
some various things that's already
cooked I put my myself in the background
while you were explaining that hahaha
this is mamrie knows how to cook and I'm
the sous chef what are we doing first
figuring out how to turn this on it's
already warm oh my god it says caution
hot I just keep high-fiving it like a
child
nothing this is heating up there's some
crazy-ass spices in this dish what kind
of spices we should've talked about
anything before we did this first we're
gonna toast some spices let's put in a
few whole cloves
oh we're just putting em straight in
we're gonna toast it and then add the
liquids oh we're so close to the
premiere of Hannah Hart's new Sean's
I'll take it now we've got star anis I
put in three of these what is that they
look like dehydrated starfish it it
imparts a licorice like flavor with a
note of sweetness
perfect for pho panna is a star yes
and anis has an aunt she's man Oh
then our third one we have a whole
cinnamon stick we didn't realize before
coming to this office that Hana already
had whole cinnamon sticks here you guys
probably all knew that because you've
kept up with her videos as of late we're
good friends when we need to be I think
she's got a future she should really
stick with it and if you don't watch it
that's a sin come on
among the model I'm sorry get in there
smell it yep this smells like Christmas
this doesn't smell they're so weird that
this is what fun is
Josefa is a lot like friendship we
consider ourselves best friends forever
because it is there for you when you've
done something bad and then it also it
always helps you get the [ __ ] out of you
yeah in my case this might be fo fo-fo 5
doesn't in a wrap biscarrat ones don't
want to vegetate that ludacris don't
need to agitate you but it's in your
nature and like a good people a studious
okay now we're gonna throw in some
fresher stuff it says some garlic so
what I'm gonna do is throw in that wait
you don't take the know because you
strain it to get all this you don't want
to bite all that star anis I don't have
dental insurance you don't have health
insurance it's one little dab
but that's like life we just put a bunch
of things into your person and then
hopefully throughout the years you just
straighten out all the good that is very
I Hannah I don't know yeah well that is
fragrant as [ __ ] the garlic or the
ginger you we're gonna chop up some
ginger I'm gonna put some broth in some
water and then we're gonna let that
simmer simmer simmer we're gonna do to
this broth what we do to Hannah
strain it that's true I'm so proud of
her
Mamie is obsessed with Food Network and
the fact that her best friend has a show
on it like she's containing excitement
last night I watched just on my own
volition five episodes of beat Bobby
Flay don't look prettier so then we put
in a quarter of an onion now it's
starting to smell more like the smells
that I associate with that's positive
side who knows that my nose knows how to
smell here's the funniest thing about
our relationship with Hannah you both
pun yeah but Hannah accuses you have not
knowing what a pun it she gives me a pun
for my money you kidding I got no money
so now I'm gonna add some veggie broth
to the pot yeah to the pot I'm gonna add
wine to memory class all around whoa
this smells amazing already now I'm
gonna add some water I build it like
halfway I'm gonna do one part water to
two parts broth I have no idea what I'm
doing
it's like one part Hannah two parts
dumbass sister just have a burger shop
and no Hannah doesn't like bodily
functions that's a boy we've done this
bar soundboard challenge a few times now
a couple twice I forget every time that
she does not find farts as hilarious as
we do also side note we're using low
sodium broth you know the three of us
have what some might call a really solid
sisterhood but today we have a
brotherhood okay okay if you want to
come over and eat some fun and pay me
for sex
I got a brothel that's just me
advertisement Craigslist advertisement
spoken out loud you guys it's bubbling
it's [ __ ] looking beautiful get their
snippet how bad it smell from here get
in there though blue a little majestic I
don't think it reads we just watched
Hannah's video for making a souffle and
it worked well people they may assume
Flay is hard I just made was drunk so
we're very proud of her good job Hannah
yep
that's all brand for this video
is there any tequila in here you have
your coffee tequila Hannah this is for
you nothing goes better with foie than
coffee tequila
we couldn't find shot glasses so I hope
you give Hannah show a shot you'll be
coughing from laughter cuz she's so
charming it'll measure up oh I have
cavities I have cavities here we are
with the final outcome of the food but
you don't know anything about this yet
you can learn all about how we finished
this harto inspired me over on May race
channel go check it out because things
got drunker and more delicious daresay
that bite was too hot I just looked in
the Seine that entire time you were
talking if you ever wanted to know what
memories channel is like she doesn't
gave you a very very deep insight into
it come on over I'll welcome you with
open arms like a sweet southern mom on a
front porch she calls our cooter arms
[Laughter]
this is really good I'm saying that
because we have collectively drank a
bottle of wine and bottle of vodka no my
case doesn't change except in men when
I'm drunk
boo boo